هذا صحيح ، طلبت قناة CNN من المشاهدين
إرسال أسئلتهم حول
فيروس كورونا
وهناك الكثير من الأسئلة والكثير من
الالتباس ، لذا دعني أرى ما إذا كان بإمكاني الحصول
على عدد قليل من الأسئلة على الأقل ، وهي بعض
من أكبر الأسئلة التي نطرحها.  إعادة التعرف
أولاً على من هو الأكثر عدوى عندما
يتعلق الأمر بفيروس كورونا ، هذا
سؤال مهم
بالأمس فقط قضيت وقتًا مع
رئيس مركز السيطرة على الأمراض والوقاية منها ، مراكز السيطرة على
الأمراض الذي قال بشكل أساسي انظر كما تعلم
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالأشخاص الذين يمكنهم نقل
أصبح الفيروس واضحًا جدًا الآن أنه حتى
الأشخاص الذين ليس لديهم أي أعراض والذين
ليسوا مرضى على الإطلاق ولكنهم يحملون
الفيروس في أجسادهم لا يزالون قادرين على نقل
هذا ، ومن الواضح أن هذا مثير للقلق ولكنهم
أضافوا أيضًا أن الأشخاص
الأكثر إصابة  الأشخاص المرضى الذين
يسعلون ويعطسون بنشاط
سيكونون هم الأشخاص الأكثر احتمالية
لنشر الفيروس بالفعل ، فهم ينشرون الفيروس بالفعل
من خلال
قطرات الجهاز التنفسي في الهواء في
بعض الأحيان.  يمكن أن تؤثر بشكل مباشر على
الأشخاص أو يمكن لتلك القطيرات أن تصل إلى
الأسطح التي يلمسها الأشخاص تلك الأسطح
ثم يلمسوا أنوفهم أو أفواههم
، وهذه طريقة شائعة لانتقال هذه الفيروسات
، لذا فإن القواعد الأساسية
لأي نوع من أنواع البرد أو الأنفلونزا هي نفسها إذا
كنت مريضًا
إذا كنت بصحة جيدة ، ابق بعيدًا عن المرضى ،
اغسل يديك كثيرًا
إذا لم تلمس الأسطح قدر
الإمكان ولا تلمس أنفك في فمك
أو عينيك بعد أن تلمس هذه
الأسطح ، تنطبق الأساسيات هنا
سؤال آخر  هل هذا أكثر خطورة
من الأنفلونزا ثم الأنفلونزا الموسمية
هذا سؤال مهم وأريد
أن أتأكد من أننا نقدم السياق الصحيح
الذي سمعت فيه عن عدد
الأشخاص المصابين بفيروس كورونا
وعدد الأشخاص الذين لقوا حتفهم  من
فيروس كورونا ، يمكنك إلقاء نظرة على الأرقام التي
تظهر على الشاشة الآن ، انظر إلى
أرقام الأنفلونزا الموسمية هذا الموسم ،
وقد توفي 14000 شخص في الولايات المتحدة وحدها
بسبب الأنفلونزا وكان هناك 26
مليونًا أو نحو ذلك  عدوى الأنفلونزا حتى
يمكنك أن ترى أن الأرقام المطلقة
هي بوضوح أعلى ، المزيد من الإصابات
المزيد من الوفيات ولكن النسبة أقل بكثير
مع الإنفلونزا ، لذا فإن
هذه الأرقام تتحرك بأرقام لذا
فمن الصحيح أن الأنفلونزا شيء
يجب أن نكون عليه تمامًا  منتبه
- لكننا لا نريد التقليل من
تأثير فيروس كورونا ، هذا فيروس جديد ،
ولسنا متأكدين تمامًا من
كيفية تغييره ، ولا نعرف بالضبط
كيف سيتصرف ، لذلك لا
يزال هناك الكثير من الأسئلة المفتوحة  حول
فيروس كورونا ، هل هناك علاج ، وهذا
سؤال آخر مرة أخرى ، ضع في اعتبارك
أننا نتعامل مع فيروس
بدأنا للتو في التعرف عليه
خلال الأسابيع العديدة الماضية في الشهرين الماضيين ،
لذلك ينشغل العلماء في العمل في محاولة
لفهم أفضل  هذا الفيروس بالضبط
كيف سيتصرف لا يوجد علاج
حتى الآن ولكن هذا لا ينبغي أن يفاجئك
أنه لا يوجد علاج لنزلات البرد
ولا يوجد علاج للأنفلونزا حتى الآن
هناك لقاح مختلف عن اللقاح.
لذلك عندما يتعلق الأمر بفيروس كورونا ،
فإن الطريقة التي يتم
علاجه بها عادةً هي علاج الأعراض ،
وعلاج الأعراض التي يعاني منها شخص ما
نتيجة الإصابة التي يجب أن أشير إليها
، وقد يكون هذا قليلًا من
الأخبار الجيدة في كل هذا.  يبدو أن
نسبة كبيرة من الأشخاص الذين على
الرغم من إصابتهم بفيروس كورونا هذا
لديهم عدد قليل جدًا من الأعراض ، إن وجدت على
الإطلاق ، لذلك لا نعرف بالضبط عدد
الأشخاص الذين يحسبون لأن هؤلاء الأشخاص
قد لا يذهبون إلى الطبيب أو هم  قد لا
يذهبون إلى العيادة ، وقد لا يتم اختبارهم ،
لكن هذا سبب آخر يجعل
نسبة الوفيات عندما يتعلق الأمر
بفيروس كورونا قد لا تعالج حتى الآن
ولكن علاج الأعراض
بالتأكيد تعلم أن هذا سيذهب إليك
ومن الواضح أنه أمر مهم  الاستثمار
في نفس اليوم الذي أكد فيه مركز السيطرة على الأمراض (CDC) اليوم الخامس عشر
لنا  حالة فيروسات التاجية دخلت
مركز عمليات الطوارئ بالوكالة
مع المدير د.  روبرت ريدفيلد ، ما مدى
جودة البنية التحتية للصحة العامة
في تقديم التقارير لإعطائك فكرة عن
مدى سرعة تغير الوضع من
خلال الطريقة التي تغيرت بها الأرقام ، يمكنني أن
أخبرك أنه في الواقع 15 هناك الكثير
لمواكبة ما هو الأسوأ-
سيناريو الحالة هنا في الولايات المتحدة حتى
الآن ، لقد تمكنا من احتوائه ولكن
أعتقد أن هذا الفيروس ربما يكون معنا
بعد
هذا الموسم ، وأعتقد أن
الفيروس سيجد في النهاية موطئ قدم
وسنحصل على مجتمع  - النقل القائم على الإرسال
ويمكنك البدء في التفكير فيه بمعنى
الإنفلونزا الموسمية ، والفرق الوحيد هو أننا
لا نفهم هذا الفيروس وهذا هو
بالضبط سبب رغبة مركز السيطرة على الأمراض في أن يكون على
الأرض في الصين ، فمن المحتمل أن تكون الحقول الحمراء
أكبر إحباط في الوقت الحالي  لا يوجد
دليل لي على أن هذا التفشي
تحت السيطرة على الإطلاق ، فمن المؤكد أنه لم يتم
السيطرة عليه ، وكلما أسرعنا في مساعدتهم في
السيطرة عليه ، كان ذلك أفضل
للعالم بأسره ، لذا أعتقد أن هذا
يثير المهمة  لماذا نجلس
هنا في أتلانتا نتحدث عن هذا
مقابل وجود مركز السيطرة على الأمراض في الصين لجمع
بعض هذه البيانات لا أعتقد أنه
قرار طبي أننا لم
تتم دعوتنا فيما تعتقد أنه جيد
، أعتقد أنه أعلاه  الطب الذي تعتقد
أنه سياسي ، أعتقد أنه فوق المستوى
الطبي ، لا أعتقد أن مدير
مركز السيطرة على الأمراض يتخذ هذا القرار ، تعتقد
أنه قرار سياسي جيدًا ، أعتقد
أن كل ما يمكنني قوله هو أنني أعتقد أنه أعلى
من مدير مركز السيطرة على الأمراض لأنه  أعلم أنه
سيحب أن يكون لديه كنظام
قبلت الصين المساعدة من منظمة الصحة
العالمية ، ينتظر مركز السيطرة على الأمراض لمعرفة
ما إذا كان سيصبح جزءًا من هذا
الفريق في هذه الأثناء يقول ريدفيلد إن
أولويته هي الحفاظ على سلامة الأمريكيين
قضيتنا برمتها.  الآن كما قلت ،
احتواء صارم لمحاولة منحنا
مزيدًا من الوقت ، لكن الأمر سيستغرق من عام
إلى عامين للحصول على ذلك على
الأرجح للتطوير والاستعداد
للأنظمة الصحية لتكون قادرة على أن تكون
مرنة بما يكفي للتعامل معها
السبب الرئيسي الثاني المحتمل للإصابة
بأمراض الجهاز التنفسي
، وكما تقول يوم الأحد ، لا يزال هناك
الكثير من الأشياء المجهولة عندما يتعلق الأمر
بكون هذه الحرائق جديدة جدًا من
حيث اللقاحات العلاجية حيث نحن موجودون لأن
هناك بعض الاقتراحات من المسؤولين في
ووهان أن بلازما الدم من
يمكن استخدام الناجين كعلاج.
العدوى
يحتوي دمهم الآن على تلك الأجسام المضادة
إذا أخذت شخصًا ناجًا أو
تعافى من هذه العدوى ، فأخذ دمائه ،
فقد تكون قادرًا على استخدام الأجسام المضادة
كنوع من اللقاح لأشخاص آخرين ،
وهذه ليست الفكرة دائمًا  العمل ولكن في
بعض الأحيان يمكن أن يكون ذلك وقصيرًا في الحصول على لقاح
، فهو خيار جيد محتمل
وتذكر أنك تعرف السبب الكامل
وراء هذا الاحتواء.
ليس لأننا نعتقد أنه يمكننا
حماية بلدان معينة من
فيروسات صغيرة لا تحترم الحدود ، فالأمر
كله يتعلق بكسب الوقت حتى يتمكنوا
من اكتشاف استراتيجيات مثل تلك التي
تصفها في الواقع.
أعتقد أن هذا الطالب الجامعي البالغ من العمر 21 عامًا
والذي طلب منا الاتصال به تايجر يي قال إنه
كان يحضر دورات لغة في
مدرسة في أوائل يناير بالقرب من
سوق المأكولات البحرية في ووهان الذي يُعتقد أنه نقطة
الصفر للفيروس الثاني ، بدأ يشعر
بالألم والمرض في معدته في
في منتصف شهر يناير في البداية حاول
معالجته بأدوية البرد ولكن مع
مرور كل يوم ساءت حالته ثم
بدأ يعاني من الحمى وقرر الذهاب إلى
المستشفى وجد في النهاية مستشفى أقل
ازدحامًا على استعداد لاختبار حالته
التشخيصية الإيجابي مما أتاح له الوصول السريع
إلى الأدوية المضادة للفيروسات التي يقول إنها أثبتت
فعاليتها في غضون أسبوع ، قال إنه
يشعر بالفعل بتحسن في الدردشة
بالفيديو معنا من مدينة قريبة في
ووهان إنجين البالغ من العمر 31 عامًا
يصف إيير تشخيصه الأولي لقد كنت
خائفًا وخائفًا من إصابتي
بهذا المرض ، وقال إن إجراء الاختبار استغرق
أيامًا بسبب ندرة موارد اختبار المستشفى
عندما تم تأكيد حالته أخيرًا
وتم قبوله
للعلاج ، وكان يشعر بالثقة في قدرته
على محاربة المرض على ما أعتقد
بالنسبة للشباب والأقوياء ، فإن المرض
يشبه الزكام الشديد فقط
لأنه شديد العدوى ، لذا فهو يسبب الذعر